LISA BLOOM: Well,
hello everyone.
And thank you so much
for joining us here
at Talk at Google.
And we're here at Google LA.
My name is Lisa Bloom.
And I'm very privileged
to have the opportunity
to interview Gene Baur.
I'll tell you about
Gene in a second.
I'm a civil rights attorney
here in Los Angeles.
I do race and sex
discrimination cases,
police excessive force cases.
I'm also an author and
legal analyst for NBC News.
And I appear frequently on CNN
and another networks talking
about the big legal
issues of the day.
But for today, I'm
here in my role
as vegan and an animal activist.
I am personally a
very passionate vegan
and animal rights person.
I've been vegetarian since
1977, vegan since 2009.
And I'm here to say that it's
a very easy, wonderful life not
participating in animal cruelty.
I thought it would be difficult,
but in fact, it's very easy.
But enough about me.
I'm here to interview Gene Baur.
Gene is the president and
co-founder of Farm Sanctuary.
And he's going to tell
us more about that.
And he's also the author
of this wonderful new book,
"Living the Farm Sanctuary
Life-- The Ultimate
Guide to Eating
Mindfully, Living Longer,
and Feeling Better Every Day."
And who doesn't want to
have all of those things?
So I'm going to
interview Gene for a bit.
And then we're going to
have questions and answers.
I always love live
events because I
feel like it's a great
opportunity for everybody
to participate
and ask questions.
We're actually here
live, in the flesh.
This is not TV.
So please ask us questions and
please interact at the end.
And don't be shy.
I'm sure Gene is willing to
answer any questions that you
have.
So, Gene, can you tell us a
little bit about Farm Sanctuary
and how it got started?
GENE BAUR: Yeah.
Farm Sanctuary is
an organization
that works to protect
farm animals from cruelty,
to challenge the
factory farming system,
to change how our society
views and treats these animals,
and to promote more mindful
compassionate living.
Most people are humane.
Most people are against cruelty.
But most people are unwittingly
supporting a cruel system
through their food choices.
And this is something
we grow up with.
I grew up eating animals without
really thinking about it.
So at Farm Sanctuary,
we just want
people to think about
the way we're living.
And ultimately to
make choices that
are aligned with
their own values
that we can feel good about,
instead of what often happens
when the topic of factory
farming or animal slaughter
comes up.
People say don't tell me.
I don't want to know.
Because it's upsetting.
And the fact that
it is upsetting
speaks to how it is not
aligned with our humanity
and our compassion.
And we also grew up believing
we need animal foods for health.
We need meat for
protein, for example.
But we don't.
So a big part of
what we do is dispel
these myths and these beliefs.
And so Farm Sanctuary is
a place where the animals
are our friends, not our food.
We started by
visiting factory farms
and documenting
conditions, finding
living animals
thrown in trash cans
or on piles of dead animals.
So it started as an
investigation and an expose
of factory farming.
And partly to heal
ourselves, as well as
to help individual animals,
we started rescuing animals
because seeing horrible
thing after horrible thing is
difficult. And it
does something to you.
It does something to people
that work in these industries.
And I feel bad for people
that work at slaughterhouses.
I just saw something
this morning
online about a case in Ohio
where an egg factory and people
involved with it are being
charged with slave labor.
So people that work
in these places
are also not treated well.
To me, being vegan,
really, is an aspiration
to live as kindly as possible.
And not eating animal foods and
choosing to eat plants instead,
is a pretty easy way to do that.
And if somebody can't
do it overnight,
they can do it incrementally.
And that's a big part of
what the book's about.
LISA BLOOM: There's a great part
in the book about small steps
you can take.
Because I think
for a lot of people
the idea of going vegan
entirely seems really extremely
and difficult and scary.
Even though I'm here
to say it's not.
But I want to talk about
those small steps in a minute.
But what is a Farm
Sanctuary for people
who aren't familiar with it?
GENE BAUR: It's a sanctuary
where the animals get
to live out their lives.
And we have three farms.
One in Watkins Glen, New York,
one in Northern California,
and one in Acton.
And so if they're sick, we
take them to the veterinarian.
Whereas on factory
farms and in production,
if an animal is sick, they're
oftentimes just left to die
or sent to slaughter.
Because, financially, if
an animal's worth $10,
or if it's a chicken
they're worth even less.
It's not worth it economically
to spend $50 on a veterinarian.
So the animals are our
friends at Farm Sanctuary.
And it's a place
where people get
a chance to interact with
them, to come up and give
a pig a belly rub.
Like 800 pound pigs, you walk up
to them, you touch your belly,
they flop over for a belly rub.
LISA BLOOM: Aww.
GENE BAUR: We do other
events at the farm
where we encourage people
just to think differently
about these animals.
For Thanksgiving every
year we do a celebration
for the turkeys, where the
turkeys are our guests, not
the main course.
So we turn the tables.
And, of course, have vegan food.
LISA BLOOM: I always say,
if we can pardon one turkey,
as the president does every year
in the weirdest political event
of the year.
Every year, right?
That weird turkey pardon.
If we can pardon one, why
can't we pardon them all?
And I've been to your Farm
Sanctuary Thanksgiving event.
And it's a wonderful event.
And I encourage everybody
to check that out.
GENE BAUR: But it's really
true, though, how we
have this big public pardoning.
LISA BLOOM: It's so bizarre.
GENE BAUR: And at
the same time, we
have millions of
dead bird bodies
on plates around the country.
So there's this irony, and this
disconnect, and this conflict,
in a sense, between sort of
our humanity and our compassion
and our desire to live
well without causing harm.
And one of the
things that we say
is, if we can live well without
causing unnecessary harm,
why wouldn't we?
LISA BLOOM: And I want
to encourage everybody
to look at the books
that are on your seats
and the seats around you.
Because there's
just these beautiful
photographs in the book
right at the beginning
and throughout the book.
As Gene says, a lot of
times, animal rights things
can bombard you with
these horrible videos
that are just very painful
and difficult to watch.
This is the opposite.
These are beautiful images.
These are positive images.
And, frankly, it's kind
of refreshing as somebody
who works in the
animal rights movement
to see the positive stuff.
And to come at this more
the carrot than the stick.
GENE BAUR: Yeah.
Seeing those ugly
images is very painful.
And sometimes people
do turn off to them
because they don't
want to see it.
I think is important to know
about that and be aware of it.
So I think those images are very
helpful in terms of advancing
awareness about these issues.
But they can be
very depressing too.
And we need to know that
there is a solution.
There is something
we can do to prevent
this abuse and this
horror from continuing.
And the good news is
that every day each of us
makes choices that
can make a difference.
There's many things
in this world that
are outside of our control.
And we feel helpless.
But when it comes to
what we eat every day,
we have a lot of
power over that.
And so being vegan
for many people,
myself included, is a very
empowering kind of statement.
It's something you can do.
It's very affirmative.
And you know, Farm Sanctuary,
in this book particularly,
is really about taking
steps and building momentum
towards living more mindfully,
more compassionately, more
healthfully.
I went vegan in 1985.
And at the time, I was primarily
concerned about animal cruelty.
And I didn't want
to support that.
But I wasn't as health oriented.
So I was eating
noodles and margarine
and not the healthiest things.
And as a vegan, you
can eat Oreos and Coke.
And that's not the
healthiest thing.
In recent years,
I've become more,
I think, holistic in this.
And trying to eat more whole
foods, all plant foods.
But more fresh plant foods,
like fruits, vegetables,
less processed food.
So I think that's an important
part of this as well.
Not only to leave animal
foods off the plate,
but to eat whole plant foods.
And it's been estimated we could
save 70% on health care costs
by eating a whole
foods, plant-based diet
in this country.
That is massive.
If you think of the cost
associated with health care.
And in addition to the pain and
suffering people experience,
if we could alleviate that,
it makes a lot of sense.
So what we're
talking about is not
only aligned with
our values, it's
aligned with our interests.
It doesn't make sense.
It's irrational to eat
food that makes us sick.
But we do that in this country.
And we die younger
than we need to.
We suffer from heart
problems and cancers
that could be prevented.
Or the risks certainly
could be lessened
by eating plant foods instead.
So this is about living in a way
that is healthy for us and then
the environment.
The United Nations
has put out a report
talking about how
animal agriculture is
the top contributor to the most
serious environmental problems
we're facing, including
climate change.
United Nations talks about how
animal agriculture contributes
more to climate change than the
entire transportation industry.
So this is another thing, where
by making food choices that
are mindful, we can take a
bite out of all these problems.
So the more you look at it,
the more sense it makes.
LISA BLOOM: So obviously,
you're obese and disease-ridden
and protein deprived.
And probably have a very
short lifespan ahead of you.
How old are you, if I may ask?
GENE BAUR: I am 52.
Gonna be 53 in a couple weeks.
LISA BLOOM: OK.
So I'm 53.
And one of the
things that we always
notice when we go
to vegan restaurants
is how everybody's in pretty
good shape and pretty healthy.
And it's kind of a
joke among vegans.
And another joke among
vegans is the question
that we always get, which is,
where do you get your protein?
And I don't mean that
in a derisive way
because it's a
legitimate question.
We've all been so
brainwashed to think
that we have to eat
animals or animal products.
Otherwise we just wither
away from lack of protein.
So can you address
that issue for those
who might be wondering?
GENE BAUR: Absolutely.
Well, we actually eat way too
much protein in this country.
And that creates
problems as well.
Excessive protein in our bodies
creates an acidic condition.
And when you have that
it has to be neutralized.
And oftentimes it is
neutralized with calcium,
which is leached from our
bodies, leached from our bones
and contributes to
things like osteoporosis.
In this country we have a huge
problem with osteoporosis.
And we also drink a
lot of cow's milk.
But we've been told that
drinking cow's milk prevents
osteoporosis.
So there's a disconnect there.
So excess protein
is more of a problem
than not enough protein.
And there's protein in things
like potatoes and broccoli,
believe it or not.
Not a lot of it,
but there is some.
If you want higher
protein content,
you can have beans, which
have plenty of protein
and also a lot of fiber.
Tofu, tempeh, whole
grains, quinoa
are good sources of protein.
Greens are good
source of protein.
But eating a whole
foods, plant-based diet
and eating a variety
of foods is probably
the best nutritional advice.
And by doing that you'll get
all the protein you need.
There's never been a
documented case of somebody
who has had protein deficiency,
if they have had enough food.
The only time you see
protein deficiency
is if people are not
getting enough food.
So if we eat just a whole
foods, plant-based diet
in a variety of things,
it does us very well.
LISA BLOOM: Yeah.
We really don't have any
problem with protein deficiency
in America.
What we do have a problem
with is fiber deficiency.
And so if you turn
on the TV, you'll
see all these ads
for yogurts and pills
that you need to take because
you have digestive problems.
And I always want to scream back
to the TV, just eat vegetables.
GENE BAUR: It's so true.
I mean if there's
one nutrient that we
need to say more Americans
need to eat, it's fiber.
I mean because that is
linked to whole plant foods.
So that really is one of
the most important messages.
So eating greens,
eating big salads
with like beans on it and nuts
or whatever you want to add,
croutons, there's
all kinds of things.
You can make some amazing salads
with a large bed of greens.
And arugula is actually
a performance enhancer
for athletes.
What I found basically there
is, you just eat the same foods,
you just have to eat a lot more,
if you're training and burning
a lot of calories.
But these greens and
especially arugula
can actually
enhance performance.
I mention Scott Jurek before,
who's an elite athlete.
He's written about this.
There's also a guy,
Patrick Baboumian,
who broke the world
record carrying
the most weight of any person.
And he's a vegan.
So he also might have some
ideas about elite performance.
For me, I would just
eat a lot more food.
And things like arugula, I found
to be a performance enhancer.
But I'm also more of
a distance person,
as opposed to,
perhaps, explosive.
And so there are, I'm sure,
plant foods that could be used.
I don't know enough
about them, though,
to give you really solid advice.
But I would do it slowly.
And dates, for example,
are pretty dense.
You probably need to go
to dense foods, nuts.
You could probably
make something
with a dried fruit and--
LISA BLOOM: Smoothies.
GENE BAUR: nut.
Smoothies are really great.
But dense foods, probably.
And you could put nut
butters in smoothies
to get additional
kick, if you needed it.
LISA BLOOM: I've
also run marathons.
And I do a lot a long
distance cycling.
And I get what you're
saying that you're hungry.
And you're big guy, right?
I love smoothies.
In fact I had one this
morning with peanut butter,
or almond butter,
or with bananas.
It's also great if you're
busy and you're on the go.
You could take it in the car.
There's a lot you can do.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
LISA BLOOM: All right.
GENE BAUR: Thank you very much.
LISA BLOOM: Thank you everybody
for turning out again.
Thank you Talk at
Google and Google LA.
Really appreciate it.
And thank you so
much, Gene Baur.
GENE BAUR: Thank you, Lisa.